i'm wondering if we can critique some
dialogue of a scene i've written the
scene is set in modern times and it
takes place in a hr human resources
department where our protagonist is maya
she's a single mom in her mid-30s
she works as an administrative assistant
she's not one for i guess what you would
call water cooler gossip she's kind of
you know head down works hard
some of the other employees don't like
her but she she kind of tunes it out the
other person in the scene is tommy and
he's a young hr professional in his
mid-20s he landed the job out of college
and he's been promoted as he's a
diligent worker and committed to seeing
the company run smoothly
so tommy has sent maya an interoffice
email and asked her to be at his office
he does not say why in the email and so
the scene takes place where maya is
knocking on the office door of tommy's
which is a jar he's at his computer so
maya says hi tommy and she knocks
hey tommy sound effect it's cool yeah
sorry yeah that's fine
and there's uh
tommy typing i don't actually have the
typing sound
oh hey maya
thanks for stopping by have a seat
please
maya sits down in the office chair
facing tommy's desk her body language is
a bit tense
tommy speaks
so and he quickly gets up from his chair
and shuts the office door
okay
maya thanks again for being here listen
tommy pauses to reflect
miley leans in
everything good
there's a little bit of an inflection in
her voice which indicates worry
tommy clears his throat and breathes in
maya as you know our company policy
states that all employees electronic
communications are monitored from time
to time so that human resources can be
certain that said employees are in
accordance with company rules and
regulations
my response
okay
tommy from october 25th maya to january
25th our i.t department noted that
within this span of time you had spent
an excessive amount of time on
non-work-related websites
during your agreed upon hours of
employment with us using a company
computer which is located at your desk
and maya interrupts tommy
wait what
what are you talking about
tommy raises his voice slightly louder
as you may remember maya from the
company handbook that was given to you
on your first day of employment with us
which you signed all computer time
within an employee's work hours should
be strictly work related
it was noted and he pulls out his little
handy-dandy pen clicking it
it was noted that you visited the
following websites on these dates and he
turns around a piece of paper that's
printed and denotes with his pen each
incident
maya looks at the paper in disbelief
and she sees on the paper a time stamp a
url of the alleged website the make
model and operating system of her work
computer
scanning the paper and shaking her head
she kind of exclaims
i don't even have an account on the
social media site and i've never been to
this blog i don't know what this is
tommy exhales and pauses
therefore maya in violation of company
policy
we're really sorry but we're going to
have to let you go
maya responds
okay wait stop
i noticed the other day there was a
login page to my computer and the
username was someone else's
i don't go to these websites
i don't even go to these websites on my
off hours so what are you talking about
gets defensive tommy interrupting my
your check has been prepared we will pay
you through 5 pm today
we will need your access card and the
key to your desk before giving you this
final check
are you able to provide these two items
for us today and so that's the dialogue
um
you want me to work yeah please okay
let's do that okay um cool by the way
fun
the first thing i'd say is we don't have
to worry about the dialogue yet okay the
first thing you have to ask is what is
the scene about
because
the person who's doing all the talking
is tommy but in fact it seems to me like
the scene is going to really be about
maya that the point of the scene is that
maya's getting fired
the other point about scene is that
she's getting fired unfairly so
one of the most important things you
have to do with each scene is say what
is this actually about dramatically what
is the center of the scene the center of
the scene is maya's getting fired
unfairly now i would need to know the
rest of the story to really work it
because the truth is if maya's getting
fired unfairly and she is going to go
out and get a much better job in a
career that she really loves like
paragliding teacher then this scene
would first of all be much shorter
because we don't really care why she got
fired unfairly so you'd want to just get
right to it in fact you know
most of the dialogue would go
but if the scene is about how
she's going to now try and find out who
did it and therefore it's going to get
into a thriller we would need to get
those details into the dialogue because
right now there isn't actually enough
specifics in tommy's accusation
so the first thing you need to do is
decide what the scene is about is it
about maya being motivated to
investigate maya being motivated to
change her life so we're talking about a
bigger question which is what's your
story about the scene is part of the
story you have to know what the story is
about then you can know what the scene
is about the scene is always about an
action
currently the only person taking an
action in that scene is tommy maya
doesn't do anything except sit down
and so one of the things i would say is
if it's maya's story which seems like it
was from the
content of the scene
you would want to give her some action
it could be begging it could be
insisting that she'd be given a hearing
it could be trying to explain it it
could be turning on tommy and saying why
he thinks he's really doing it there's a
lot of possible scenes which give maya
an important action because really what
we want to know is what's maya going to
come out of this it could be that maya's
crushed
and it's going to we're going to see her
be miserable for a long time before she
discovers paragliding teacher
so the the the dialogue it only
matters in the sense that it reflects
what the character is trying to
accomplish and what we are trying to
tell in terms of story for the character
so that's the first thing is dialogue
comes last
um the next thing about the dialogue
though i would say is
you can be a lot shorter um
you know when she walked in just as a
dialogue lesson i would say he comes and
says maya
sit down and then he says
names the the websites and the type of
website the specific
information would tell us a lot about
what this story is about assuming it is
the investigation or it's just he says
you know
i'm
sit down
you know
linens are us
uh vacations
unlimited and whatever it is we're
finding out about the person who did log
in
and it's also just more interesting
dialogue he just starts reciting these
weird things
or outrageous you know porn sites or
whatever it is terrorist sites
she's going to be like
i don't understand like she is but then
she's going to say
i saw freddie at my desk or someone at
my desk and you know that only
so and so has a key because they're my
superior whatever it is you're going to
be explaining the situation that sets up
the rest of the scene and the rest of
the
business terminology that was in the
scene should go
unless
it is possible to make it a wonderfully
suspenseful
scene in which
tommy is just
blathering on with
you know corporate double speak and
we're getting tenser and tenser not
about what's he getting to but then you
would build the scene a little
differently his speech would be more
tarantinoy in which he's
playing little mind games with her as he
does it
so it's not impossible it's not like
there's an only one way to write a scene
you can play this scene with that kind
of long speech from tommy but then
tommy's got to have a reason that he's
doing it
the actual
corporate
liability not that important
i can keep going but i probably should
stop there no i love it so i think the
first thing then i need to determine
what is it that's going to happen to
maya from this
story what's the story then what's the
scene because the scene only exists
within a story um and with the story
it's always going to be for me the same
six questions who is it about
what do they want
why can't they get it
what do they do about that
why doesn't that work
what is the end and if you think about
in this case it's like well who is it
about it's about maya or tommy or maybe
it's about someone else about somebody
that you know takes maya's job and this
whole scene should just be maya you're
fired
um but let's assume the scene's about
maya so who is about maya what does she
want does she want to keep this job or
does she want to get a better life once
you've made that what's the obstacle the
obstacle of keeping the job is she got
fired unfairly the obstacle of the new
life is she wasn't prepared for this
she's broke
what does she do about that if
each one if she wants the job back she
has to find out who did this or find out
what tommy's up to or she would take
those
actions always asking
what is the story about and the story is
going to be about a character wanting
something
and so
story is about she needs this job she
has this son
and
you know she's kind of been left to pay
a bunch of bills and money's tight for
her and she doesn't like this job but
she really needs it
um
that's that's part of the story i guess
there has to be more of
what is going to happen to her life well
then you have to decide yeah in a big
picture what story do i want to tell do
i want to tell the story of someone who
takes on the corporate bad guys is it
about someone who
stumbles on a sinister plot
is it someone you know
whatever kind of story you want to tell
is really going to make that
determination what kind of story do you
like if you like the sinister plot story
or if you like the she's going to team
up with a whole bunch of other people
who are unfairly fired and create their
own company you know i mean there's all
sorts of it could start be the start of
a comedy or it could be the start of the
thriller
right and so with the dialogue it should
be much more to the point don't worry
about the corporate double speak unless
i was really going to do this crazy sort
of tarantino-esque in theory less is
more on dialogue but not always some
great long scenes exist it just had
better be worth it it better be
something that is creating some
set piece moment where something
extraordinary is happening not just a
big turning point but we're getting a
sense of the style of these characters
in this movie that's going to be all
about mind games or all about taking
down tommy because he's such an ass
right like glenn gary glenn ross exactly
those long scenes and and shows these
salesmen and kind of like what their
style was and
different things right and so this is
not that i don't think that there are
there's really any absolute rule like
keep dialogue short although in general
keep things short because
we like to move along but truthfully
it's more a matter of finding the model
that you are trying to be like if you're
saying yes i want to
have a really dialogue heavy
intricate character-based drama
then keeping it short is not always to
your advantage it depends you just have
to make certain choices everything is a
choice and every choice has a price you
have to decide what type of thing you're
trying to do make the choice to do that
and then you build every other thing
based on those choices
you